hey what's up guys you know what usually
on Sundays I do a Q&A Sunday and I
answer questions from YouTube
the thing is I'm gonna do that and I'm
gonna keep doing that but I've had so
many questions on other platforms as
well like Instagram and Facebook and
with you so I thought this time what
I'll do is I would answer right now
some Twitter questions and I'll go
through and some of you guys might be
following on different platforms and if
you're not then do jump on to Instagram
and Twitter and Facebook connect with me
so I'm going to answer some Twitter
questions right now but then if you have
questions and you're watching this on
youtube comment your questions below and
then next time I'll be answering your
questions so I look forward to hearing
your questions so let's see what we've
got on Twitter and I haven't even really
thought about the answers I'm going to
say I'm just going to read the questions
read the answers and see what we got
so Michael McCaul says how do you can't
part mentalize risk psychologically when
you first start out how I assess risk is
the same when I first start out is
really now in fact you might think when
you first start out that it's riskier
it's actually decisions and property
investments get riskier the more
successful you become be white because
you've got more to lose so when you're
starting out if you're starting out with
10,000 pounds and that's all you've got
in the world you haven't got that much
to lose so it doesn't really matter too
much and what I do is before I make any
decision firstly I look at the return on
investment so before I'm doing a deal
before I'm taking on and a deal is risk
every decision that you make is risk and
anyone that thinks that you can invest
in property or do anything 100 percent
risk-free is actually deluded because
the definition of an entrepreneur is
someone that takes risks in the hope to
make money so but the biggest risk you
can ever you can ever make is not
stepping out you know dying knowing that
you could have done so much more
but anyway so firstly I look at the
return on investment I just look at the
straight facts and figures but then what
I do is I'll look at the best case and
the worst case and the likely case and
depending on those outcomes if
if the best-case scenario is going to be
I'll make a million pounds on this deal
and the worst case is I'll lose
everything and I'll become financially
crippled and be divorced and and and it
will ruin my reputation and I'll lose
other people's money and that's that's
the worst I'm already not that excited
anymore about the million because the
worst is really bad but then I'm gonna
look at the likely case what's the
likely case the likely case is I might
make a hundred grand I'm just I'm going
to do it for the sake of probably making
a hundred grand I'm not going to risk
losing everything however if the worst
case is look if it all goes wrong if
everything worked files I might lose ten
grand if it goes to plan I'll make a
million and I'll probably make a hundred
grand I'm then going to do it so it's
just looking at the best case worst case
likely case
probability of that also having exit
strategies in place and what if I really
don't know what to do if I'm really
unsure this is this is how I make a
decision I'll say what would I advise my
best friend to do okay if I'd advise my
best friend to do it then I'll advise
myself the same because sometimes it's
easier to advise your friend than it is
to advise yourself so that's the kind of
thing I look at make sure you're making
the decision based on logic rather than
fear you should never make a position on
fear and that's how I decide when to
take on risk I hope that answered your
question
jeez I than the whole video on that for
real okay mark said where are the
solicitors they know about Lease Option
agreements I've not been able to find
one for a love of trying okay it's a
difficult one because there's not that
many sisters the deal with Lease Option
agreements there's only a few and I used
to give out my whole Power Team on
YouTube and everything but my Power Team
start getting really worked up with me
so I wouldn't want to just on YouTube
recommend specialist solicitors because
I don't want him to get bombarded but
what I would probably say is jump on the
Facebook groups find people that are
doing deals and then tap into their
power team the best way to vote any
Power Team is to just find people that
are successful even may like if you come
down to any of any of my advanced
training you
have dinner with my whole Power Team
potentially so foreign people are doing
it ask them for referrals
referrals always the best way to build a
Power Team sorry if I couldn't be any
more helpful who else we got
ok investment consolidations I'd like to
ask a bit about time frame with Grant
Cardone what message you got from the
enterprise interesting see some feedback
on the trip
I guess I've met Grant cotton a couple
times now and he came on my youtube
channel which was really cool and then I
went down to Miami and spent a week with
him and did a one-on-one mentoring to
the biggest thing I got from Grant
Cardone was that he is a big thinker
like really big thinker and also he's
he's really mastered the art of using
other people's money and I think for me
the way I got started was using other
people's money and joint venture Inc but
then as I became more successful I was
using my own money for everything in
fact I was funding other people's deals
only but grant was like dude you're only
going to grow so big if you do that you
need to really continue to leverage your
money and I think he just he just it was
a bit of a mind screw to be honest but
he's way like he's operating on a level
which not many people are and he's one
of the few people that I will pay to
mentor me because he's harmful it's hard
to find mentors when you get to a
certain point but grant is he's good
so I enjoyed it and I've got way more
sessions booked with him as well so I'll
keep you posted on how that goes and all
the stuff that I pay hundreds of
thousands of pounds learning from my
mentors I'll share as much as I can for
free on YouTube to you guys because I
believe what goes around comes around
repeat what you say ok ro Dix so you put
a lot of contracts on social media which
has a lot of value I get a house HMO or
whatever the case may be I think it's a
good deal how do I get legal contracts
to make the deal to the next step to
close the deal it depends on the deal
dude if you get a deal and you want to
if you buy the house you need to get a
solicitor so if you've got HMO where
you're buying a property you just need
the solicitor and you don't need a
special solicitude to buy a normal house
you're only the special solicitor to
drop a special kind of agreement but
just just guess mister for sure okay
Mack my size
you help me get my first one as guidance
they don't do it myself of the knowledge
that I get yeah man I'll help you get
your first deal just that's what I do
bro I put YouTube videos out I put
training on and your first deals always
your hardest why don't you put your
first deal and you bend it properly with
the correct training and support you can
just duplicate that again and again and
again and that's what I've some of my
students and now like doing crazy things
because they're just duplicating again
again what they learned so yeah you know
where I'm at I'll leave a link in the
description with a free two day property
investors crash course because you'll
love that it'll definitely give you
enough to get started ok JM what's the
number one reason that inspires you to
achieve more ok great question what
inspires me to achieve more is
significant success is great but once
you've tasted significant success wanes
a little bit and I think seeing the
impact that I'm having upon people and
the stories and the lives that I'm
helping I know it sounds cheesy but it
really drives me and also I think just
being the best version of myself I can
possibly be you know I want to
continually get to a new potential a new
level and it's easy to think that when
you become financially free then
suddenly it would just be you can just
relax
and whilst you can relax in my
experience when you have the choice to
work you'll probably relax for a couple
weeks and then you'll get to work but
because you're working from a position
of choice and abundance you'll actually
work harder and you'll actually become
more focused and more mission driven so
that's like me now Scott first part of
that where do you think is a good time
to start a really parent Scott I mean
I'm so many factors I think the Midlands
is pretty good for buy-to-let because
the Midlands is close to everything is
the center of the country and house
prices are pretty cheap but not
ridiculously cheap and there are some
pretty nice parts so I'm gonna say
Birmingham but there's so many different
factors depends on what you want to get
out of it how would you do it for
someone with bad credit asking for a
friend of course you are Josh saw bridge
I know your credits perfect so if you've
got bad credit what would I do I do a
few things firstly I'll be working a mic
ready
better secondly I would be doing
strategies that don't require you to
have good credit namely rent two rents
maybe or lease options or deal packaging
while getting cash flow but also
experience thirdly if you really want to
buy a house you've got my credit I'd
partner if someone do a joint venture
with someone who has not got bad credit
so that way 11 yeah so you can do it
maybe a guarantor or a mortgage host or
a joint venture partner so there's just
some solutions hope perhaps okay andrew
says how to balance between being a
caring landlord and not overspending on
property great question
Andrew I think I used to be a little bit
tighter than I am now
but that's because I didn't have that
much money so if something wasn't great
with the proper tools if the terms have
been there five years and they move out
and I'm thinking these tenants the new
tenants could redo the new carpet but a
new carpets going to cost me a thousand
pounds and I don't have a thousand
pounds so it makes it it makes it more
difficult now sometimes I probably
overspend and I think that it's really
tough one I think the key is number one
making sure that you're being reasonable
and fair so it have a tenants got a nice
home have you are you providing a good
standard I think that's the first thing
secondly is you want to be looking at
return on investment for everything so
sometimes you can go a bit it's
impossible to work out the exact return
on investment but if you get nice new
carpets even though you don't have to
you're gonna get nicer tenants the
tenants are gonna pay more rent their
terms are gonna stay longer so it's just
looking in look it's a ground but I'm
probably going to make that back because
of all the things I've just mentioned so
I think just making sure that the house
I wouldn't go crazy you know don't don't
get it like really expensive carpets
because you'll be demoralizes a landlord
if you spend thousands of pounds on
really fancy carpets that you might have
in your own house and then the tenants
move and don't value that don't
appreciate that spill coffee have dogs
and cats ruining it it's just really
irritating how to start with real estate
Mattie Oh Olivia just keep watching my
videos dude keep watching my videos Stan
Smith how do you get paid through a limb
company do you have a salary or take
monthly dividends okay that really
depends on how you structure the company
I mean I pay myself a wage but I would
definitely go and speak to an accountant
about how your company how you're gonna
take money from it
well it probably suggests in the early
days just don't don't take any money
from it
all the money that your company makes
I'd reinvest it into property I'd
reinvest it in the company as long as
you can as long as you can cloud how can
I get a job with a band on tour without
any musical experience or skills I think
you're probably asking the wrong dude
actually I don't know how you can get a
job with a band without any musical
experience or skills but I'm sure I take
no I'm going to answer that I don't know
why you asked me that question learn to
sell if you can sell well ie sell
yourself you can get pretty much just
about any job in the world you want so
learn to sell okay Lewis is it smarter
to stick to one side business to fully
expand it or focus is having multiple
side businesses better okay I think you
want two businesses you want a business
which is focused on cash flow bringing
in cash flow and then you want a
business that's focused on investing in
a long term security building wealth
legacy to businesses so in property you
could for instance you can have a
business that's deal sourcing so you're
selling deals with bringing you quick
cash and then you're then investing that
into property buy-to-let if you are you
know if you've got another business
that's really exciting maybe you're a
musician or you are a solicitor or
whatever and you've got a business and
you're thinking I don't want property to
be a distraction it won't be just focus
on making a cash flow in your business
and then investing smartly with that
money so two businesses and if you want
more you can have more but that would be
a general rule of thumb so you want fast
pound and slow pound working together to
create wealth and build legacy what
skills do you believe should be required
for any business to be successful this
is from Lewis again please stay away
from obvious answers like dedication
determination etc I'm talking about
skills you can work with and freelance
okay so sales set sales is the most
important skill on the planet because
when you're doing property even even
proper to any business you didn't with
people your house is your product and
your tenant is your customer but
ultimately the money doesn't come from
the product it comes from the customer
so being able to sell a tenant or moving
in and paying you rent being able to
sell and investor on selling you their
property below market value being able
to sell a joint venture partner on
coming up it's all about they're able to
speak to people create win-win
situations and value and influence
people and get people to do business
with you so sales is the number one
skill do you have one hundred
twenty-four thousand pounds to lend me
so I can get my first teacher mo deal
I'm about to lose over the line since my
investor pulled out says to your
property investments unfortunately I
don't because I don't know you I do back
people's deals and fun people's deals
quite often but they tend to be people
that I know who remind be my students
people on the Academy so appreciate the
question and really hope that you manage
to get the money if you haven't already
and good job in asking because hey if
you don't ask you don't get okay Cal Oak
G says can you mentor me yes I can
mentor you but you have to pay and it's
not G but yeah I can mentor you man
absolutely
but in my luck you might not need
mentoring from me you might need to just
take action on the knowledge that you
already know so I think mentors are
really important but more important is
just getting the you know again having
the knowledge and the training but being
able to motivate yourself so yeah that's
what I say will you let me be part of
your team and work for you too Sam Jones
come back for an interview buddy its
recruitment at Samuel leagues calm and I
think that is just about everything
whether it's easier to get a reply off
you via Twitter or Facebook I don't know
man
III said I check Facebook probably more
I check Instagram and YouTube the most
Twitter I'm answering all my Twitter
questions right now so I guess it's a
good W you asked on Twitter but I try
and check as many as I can as often as I
can I have a great team as well that
sometimes respond to messages when I'm
busy or an out of town
but anyway that's everything I hope that
was helpful if you've been watching this
on YouTube
I'd love to you get some great questions
from you as well so comment your
questions below property questions
business questions sales questions
things that are niggling you've been
bugging you for a while
comment below I'll do my very best to
answer my name is Samuel Leeds thanks
for watching if you'd like to check out
the financial freedom challenge this is
when I started all over again from
scratch with nothing I became
financially free in one week then you
can check that out right here if you'd
like to see me do the financial freedom
to move someone else and help a normal
guy over know money become financially
free you can check that out right here
or maybe you'd like to become
financially for yourself and you'd like
to come into the property investors
crash course get the tickets right here
don't forget to subscribe over here
thank you so much